Dodgers begin a three-game series
against the Nationals today and Clayton
Kershaw will take the mound tomorrow
afternoon he joins us on the program
good morning Clayton how are you
are you keeping an eye on the cowboy
situation are you a cowboy fan
I haven't Cowboys fan yeah they're
reporting to oxnard here on X Wednesday
I think but are you keeping an eye on
what's going on with Ezekiel Elliott
holding out and you know you got dak
Prescott won the contract I mean are you
that hardcore of a cowboy fan I did not
know that Zeke was holding out I have to
be honest with that I didn't know that
dad was talking about a new contract
that I didn't know about it or that but
you so you root for Matthew Stafford
individually but you root for the
Cowboys as a team yeah absolutely you
know I love watching you play I got to
go to high school with him obviously and
it's always fun to have a vested
interest effort but yeah Cowboys I grew
up and down I was my team and I still
love watching him play who throws harder
you were Stanford well I'll tell you
this Matthews a way better baseball
players and I was a football player
that's for sure he was he was really
good at baseball he could have gone to
college and played for sure I bet I bet
Matt the Emmy macking it throw a
football way better than I could throw a
football that's for sure
but didn't you didn't you help protect
him in a fight one time in high school
no late hit I was I was kind of big and
chunky and on the line and yeah
quarterback gets laid here you get a
little frustrated so the next point was
like a cut black play where it's like a
short pass getting a little sucker punch
at the end and you know I got tossed
really yeah I got a little feisty a
little feisty okay okay did you hear
from your parent like what happened when
you went home like did you get yelled at
except for the rest was just kind of you
know in the scrum of the thing but you
know it was enough for me to get to us
and had to explain myself you know I
don't think I got too much trouble
though last time you got into a fight is
that the last fight you were
if you want to call it that I've never
been like actual like this fight before
I you know yeah I feel like you know
wrestling matches or puzzles but not
actual like this fight who's the last
Dodger teammate you would want to have
in the Octagon oh that's a good question
oh please gone that's good
you know I think you know Russell Martin
Russell kind of knows all that MMA stuff
you know he's strong athletic I think
Russell would be a tough one to bring
down Kenley might be tough too
yeah Kim Lee I think I think I could
yeah I mean he's big obviously so I'll
be tough for sure
wait wait what you were gonna say what
you think you can I just I don't know I
think Russell's just like you know lower
to the ground and just stocky and feisty
I don't know I think I have a better
chance against Kindler than Russell not
saying I could take him away but I think
I have a better chance he's Clayton
Kershaw the Dodgers pitcher a three game
series against the Nationals today and
you take the mound tomorrow afternoon
have you ever gone to the stadium in
full uniform no never
wouldn't it be fun though like just
drive over get out of the car walk in
maybe take public transportation in New
York go out - what position player do
you think did you see the Orioles and
the angels where you had a position
player who came in and got the safe
first time it's ever happened in
baseball history who would be the guy
that you would want position player who
could actually get a save to Russell's
horn again because Russell's come in a
few times for us this season and he hit
90 a few times and you know everybody
talks about the speed stuff he had like
all those characteristics the spin rate
and all that stuff and I mean he looked
really good Russell there - yeah Russell
is incredible he does everything what do
you make of the Commissioner finally
coming out talking about the baseball
that maybe they've made the baseball
better
and therefore we have you know less drag
and more guys are hitting home runs here
you know where do you stand on all this
better that's for sure why did we use
the word juice though claim ok it's just
funny to me it really is it really mean
because everybody's having to deal with
it and if homeruns are what people want
to see and that's what's happening like
it's really not a big deal if you make
good pitches you're gonna get guys out
and it's just it's just funny to me that
it's such a huge deal and it's so
secretive like let's just come out it
let's just listen be honest like it's
not going to change anything we're still
gonna play
I just it'd be awesome just to know what
happened it would really be fun to know
but what do you think is going on I I
mean I've something has to be different
I mean just the amount of homeruns is
insane and it's obviously going up with
the way the game is being played and you
know more strikeouts Mauro Bronson I get
that but this year is just incredibly
it's just so different we went to Coors
Field a few weeks ago and obviously
Colorado's a little bit different in
itself but some of the home runs that
were being hit in Colorado were just
like this is this is insane like this
isn't even baseball like we're playing
on the moon right now it's just crazy
when's the last time you gave up a home
run and you went that that come on
that's not right I think I mean I've
given up plenty of home runs where you
know it's kind of on the fence I think
the one thing I'll say is guys are going
opposite field like it's like it's
nothing even in Dodger Stadium you know
Dodger Stadium is pretty fair at night
and you see some varieties and lefties
that are great hitters you know nothing
against I'm the going opposite field is
like there's only a few guys in the
league they used to be able to do that
and now it's like you know you got your
seven hole hitter going up upper tanks
you know upper deck but I saw Berlin
Verlander's giving up more home runs
than anybody in baseball and he's having
another incredible season and he said
look I'm a fly ball pitcher I'm gonna
give up home runs I'm not giving up much
more than that
do you understand that logic that I
can't change even though there's
something up with these baseball's and
if you if you take me you know out then
you take me out yeah no I think that's a
great philosophy to have and he's right
I mean he's having the dominant season
and those are probably the only runs but
he's giving up our Hall bronze and I've
always said that solo homeruns aren't
going to beat you you know if you give
up you know one solo home run even two
solo home runs a game like those are the
only runs you're going to give up you're
probably going to win the game and he's
so hard to hit that there's not going to
be a lot of traffic on the bases it's
gonna be hard for guys to string
together two or three hits an ending
anyway so he's absolutely right who do
you hate facing when you're at the plate
oh when I'm at the plate okay anybody
that throws over so that's pretty much
the entire league right yeah
unfortunately yeah but you got one home
run I do I need more you know I've been
around too long not to have not to have
a couple more you know I can end up and
batting practice I can get a couple out
you know that's my favorite part of my
day
it's just it's the best you know there's
no stress you get up there and get to go
try to hit homers and big league
ballparks I mean that's a blast did you
get the ball back when you hit that
homerun I did so there's luckily no fans
there so awesome what do you make of
these the robotic strike zones that
they're running in the Atlantic League
and the possibility what would you be in
favor of you know the eye in the sky
being the strike zone there to help out
these umpires I'm a little skeptical I
just I'm a lot skeptical I'll be honest
I just I don't know how the strike zone
works per se because you know the little
boxes on TV you know everybody says that
they're all different based on what you
know cable provider or what like network
you're watching and then you know the
strike zones 3d right so it's how do you
figure all that in and I just I don't
know you know and I think you know
obviously the balls off the plate that
you get called strikes are our balls and
I understand that so here
really gonna like that but you know Dan
the strike zone goes all the way up to
the letters like by the book so when
you're throwing fast balls at the
letters and needles to say how everybody
throws 95 miles per hour you cannot hit
that pitch you can't so if that's a
strike that's gonna be it's gonna be a
really tough time and pictures are gonna
change pictures are just gonna try and
throw the ball up there all the time now
yeah I I would like to see it maybe in
the all-star game where you could have
dialogue during the game and we could
see it and it's in a game and it's not
spring training at the umpire could be
miked and you could be talking about it
if you're on the mound you could ask you
know you know what what's the strike
zone or where was that and do it in a
conversational manner and we could be
there to witness it and I think that
might be interesting to roll it out that
way just to give you a feel of what it
could be like and it feels like you
would benefit more if you did have a you
know a true strike zone
I'm guessing yeah I guess you're right I
guess I guess you just have to see it in
action to know for sure well you're good
and a good idea I guess to do it
somewhere you know spring training also
games something just to know what what
you're dealing with and because
everybody says robotic empire and it
sounds great in theory but there's got
to be we have to try it out and I know
they're doing it and the Atlantic League
I'd be interested to see a game you know
just to see how that's going yeah I'm
curious about it I saw special and HBO's
real sports with Bryant Gumbel and I
think Eric Byrnes was the umpire and and
he took part in this and just said hey
you know what there's somebody up above
there's a strike zone and they would
buzz down and say ball or strike and
they did it in real time it wasn't like
there was a great hold up there yeah but
I'd be you know like tennis has it now
and nobody complains about any calls
because they'd say well there it is
right there but I think as viewers when
we're watching we're never right behind
you
so so the strike zone is a little bit
altered and then we'll go with it that's
a strike or that's a ball when if we're
right behind you you're gonna see a
different look or the hitter or the
catcher is as well
yeah you know I that's all true and I
can't argue with any of that the only
thing I will say is that you know
catchers take a great deal of pride and
catching the ball and presenting the
baseball to the umpire a lot of people
have jobs and get paid as catchers
because of how they present the baseball
and you're basically taking that artform
away and so but catching position
changes entirely at this point because
pitch framing is a huge deal especially
for some of the new-age front office's
and organizations as a pitcher you can
definitely tell a difference so that
that's taking jobs away right there and
making the catching position a lot more
offensive at that point and you just
have to be aware of that as well
are the kids do they get excited when
you're on the mound we're getting there
yeah you know Charlie my son just loves
baseball and it's probably my fault but
he does love this bullet you know I
think they're kind of getting to the
point where Charlie at least watch a
couple innings and cally he'll come to
the field but she's not gonna watch the
game she's gonna go the family room and
play the friends so yeah she she's not
too too into the baseball thing but she
loves to root for guys she just was
common it's awesome okay women you said
it's your fault that Charlie likes
baseball he's around it a lot what do
you want him to like you want him to
pick up golf or yeah post-retirement
I would love for him to pick up Dolph's
oh that would be great but no you know
you just as a baseball dad you just you
don't want to be you don't want to force
it on them and I swell with pride every
time you know says he wants to play
catch or hit off the tee or whatever but
you just don't want to force it on them
you just want them to have fun and play
whatever you want well have fun tomorrow
when you take the mound great to catch
up with you again and thanks for joining
us Clayton Kershaw Dodgers pitcher for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]